so what would you like me to do change
of base so I can change the basis so I
have logs and they're both
awkward-looking
right they're different bases for
starters that's kind of a clue to you
that like they don't talk the same
language just like fractions that don't
have common denominators you want do
something about that so therefore how do
I use change of baseball I can write
this guy over here is 2 times what how
would I write it log X on log 5 doesn't
matter what
log base I choose it really can't be
anything which is kind of heavy right so
I've separated out these guys into Logs
with the same base that's useful and I
don't even care what base it is also say
1 ok I can do the same thing for this
guy what's this going to become yeah
it's just upside down because the base
of the called the argument we have it
hardly ever use that word because there
are different places they swaps around
so there's my 9 log 5 on log X and
there's that 3 hang out there on the
right hand side okay excuse me
mara at this point up almost at the
quadratic
step because this is actually exactly
what I talked about before fractions
with different double use gross so how
do I get rid of them
what will I do to both sides nothing
moves nothing loose what will I do what
operation can I do to both sides I could
yeah very good if I multiplied by the
product or really it's the lowest common
multiple but in this case that's the
product of these two denominators then
all of my fractions would disappear no
just in general terms so log X log 5
will do it right what's a 10 this going
into well when you multiply it by the
log 5 the denominator is kids or that
but you've also multiplied by log X so
this becomes this I have seen people use
like intrigued addition excuse me we
right side squared X to indicate side X
all squared but not so covered with log
so I'm just going to write in longed-for
so we know exactly what we're talking
about
what's leftover Vitus 9 yeah the same
thing is happened over here right the
log X so we multiply by camps under the
run arms the log 5 ml divided by now
you've got two of them other time
and then over here you've got the whole
kit and caboodle you happy so we have
satisfactorily created the quadratic now
at this point I have a lot of logs
flying around and just for the sake of
making this easier to work with I'm just
going to introduce the substitution I'm
going to say let u equal log X and that
just says we're having to write log X
over and over again okay while I'm at it
on my next line I'm also going to get
everything over on one side so it's a
nice and easy to work with quadratic
okay so what will I get
I've got two u squared over here on the
left that's going to be the u term right
there so it goes next in order right
I'll subtract it from both sides which
gives me this I put some bracket there
why do you see that's a good idea not
necessary but a good idea yeah number
one it separates at you so I can see
this is the coefficient that I'm after
secondly is it log of 5 U or is it log
of 5 and then something else on the edit
it's just not worth being ambiguous
about that and then you've got this guy
and hanging out over the end here now
admittedly this looks messy but remember
log 5 is just a number it's just a
number
so I can deal with it like any other
number like 3 or 8 or pie or a it's fine
ok this is a quadratic right can you see
a nice easy factorization for
when you say evaluate it evaluate what
mod 5 yep so this could be whatever base
you like okay so you can do that however
I'm going to point out while that's fine
you have to be careful because it's it
for other kinds of problems that are
more complicated and will demand you to
actually choose a specific log you don't
what to do just anything so that's why
I'd say watch out we can actually deal
with this and it's probably worth flexi
algebraic muscle a little bit as it is
right as it is if for example all I have
to do is change the 5 into a program
rule and then you're kind of stuck right
so how can we deal with this without
evaluating things what do you do when
you can't factorize a quadratic you go
to the just given formula I've got a
formula for this U is going to be equal
to take a deep breath minus B which is
it's just 3 log 5 because there's a
double negative plus or minus the square
root of B squared which in this case is
3 squared B squared it's going to be 9
log 5 or squared is that my B squared by
this for a and then you come to see
look no I did already there we go before
we go any further does it check out does
it look all right did I do my
substitution correctly B squared minus
4a check it C check it looks good yeah
all over what 2a which in this case is
oh cool
now this looks disastrous but I've
expecting a lot of stuff for kids for
that here right so I've got the three
log five hanging out the front plus or
minus okay
look carefully how many log 5 squared
do I have I've got nine of them here and
then how many do I have here 8 times 9 8
times 9 is 72 right so I've got 9 of
them here and I've got plus 72 of them
there that looks to me like 81 of them
yeah that's some convenient okay so this
is looking good this is looking it's
giving us all the Q through on the right
track
this is divided through by 4 let's look
this is 3 log 5 plus or minus how many
log fives am I going to have minus them
all divided through by 4 this is 2
solutions isn't it there's the negative
1 which is minus minus 6 log 5 on the
top minus 6 log 5 that will be minus 3
on 2 log 5 ok with that and then your
other one your positive solution will be
how many low fives 12 of them divided by
4 so it's just 3 ok now I've just solved
for you but what was you again oh yes
equals so I was there I'm like one step
away for example it's a bit easier to
see on say this one right three log five
you can write that without three at the
front country what would that be log log
of 125 right so log X equals log 125 so
clearly X must be 125 like that this
one's a bit of Messier sort of
proposition but it's five to the power
of whatever that is five to the power of
minus 3 on to five to the power of minus
3 on 2 I think that's going to be Oh
help me out guys I'm actually you know
what I'm just going to write that and
then I'll deal with it later ok I've
done the hard work haven't I
what is this question about this
question is about number one it is about
your log laws because I've used it quite
a few times and secondly it's about see
the quadratic like see the forest for
the trees root one on a 125 yeah yeah
yeah which is the same thing and either
those are one on one on the square root
one hundred thirty-five yeah yeah that
make sense because that's five cubes and
then the square roots are